et la 15e nuit pendant ce mois de mai
donc on est le 29 mai que il y a des
tentatives de fabriquer mais comme à
chaque fois
presque tous les projectiles sont
abattus je pense qu'en fait pour la nuit
dernière la totalité 40 sur 40 entre
drone et missile tiré sur Kiev selon
l'armée de la ukrainienne tous ont été
abattus c'était pas le cas la nuit
précédente la nuit de samedi à dimanche
un ou deux projectile avait atteint leur
cible et un civil est mort à Kiev en
fait samedi à dimanche matin excusez-moi
mais pour la nuit dernière pas de
blessés
selon les autorités locales du moins pas
pour le moment juste dans trois
quartiers y compris les quartiers de
podil où je me trouve en ce moment il y
a eu des incendies mais qui ont été très
rapidement contrôlés par les autorités
ce n'est pas uniquement Kiev qui a été
ciblé la nuit dernière des explosions
hautes aussi été entendues
au dessin et dont les régions de
melnitzky et de le vivre mais pour le
moment les autorités là-bas aussi disent
qu'il n'y a pas de dégâts significations